[Music]
another big game this week that I have
not got the chance to play as Fire
Emblem echoes shadow of Valencia
Valencia shadow or shadows shadows of Al
India there's multiple shadows there's
multiple echos kind of ways work
fireable miss morality uh hit me whether
you play like five hours
yeah um which so there's about six
chapters in the game and I've played
almost to the end of the first one and
they really don't know what we're doing
um so past Fire Emblem games on 3ds
right they incorporated a lot of almost
dating sim like aspects yeah which is
enjoyable you know in its own way but
this game doesn't really have much of
that and it's based on a game as Kelly
mentioned called Fire Emblem Gaiden
which came out on the original Nintendo
Famicom in Japan one of the earliest
fire it's one of the earlier firemen
tank smell of mold permeates the shrine
that's tanks so one of the things you
just saw in you're currently looking at
is this third-person exploration so for
the most part in this game which let me
just wrap up that last part there's no
relationship building in the traditional
sense of Fire Emblem go ahead so sever
ties with everyone so essentially the
gameplay flow works as you move along a
map with like a linear path and there's
a couple branches that go off and you
can explore dungeons or bump into
enemies and get to tactical battles the
tactical battles are very familiar for
what most people are used to for from
Fire Emblem recently they've changed a
few mechanics so you can't pair two
people on the same tile now but there's
also no more weapon triangle so you're
not going to have like advantages or
disadvantages based on the specific
category of weapon right there's more
like um like weapon degradation
management and stuff like that rather
than no just not rot yes all right
there's more um there now I'm blanking
on what our reviewer had this excellent
paragraph all about like all the cool
changes and like departments from modern
Fire Emblem and yeah like your inventory
is very important yeah the inventory
management is kind of one of the more
strategic elements then if you're used
to modern Fire Emblem kind of like that
spear sword or an axe matchup triangle
precisely yeah
it's got a few other things going for it
like it allows you to rewind time during
battles you have you know the limited
uses based on something that you earn
but that's kind of interesting for a
game like this especially if you play
with perma death now like if you play
with perma death you're kind of supposed
to just you know deal with it when
people die like most normal people
though we can't just you know let that
happen so we want to restart our old
save and not that let that person die
but this game can just let you rewind a
few turns I rather then start all over
again
that's the coolest thing to me is like
you can obviously opt not to use it but
it's it's going to ease that like soft
resetting thing that a lot of us do with
Fire Emblem if you play with perma death
but also you have to manage because you
only have a limited amount of rewinds
you have to manage it like you could
rewind because you didn't get like a
good rng on whatever hit you did or you
could rewind to save a character and you
kind of have to make that call yeah and
you know sort of because the
relationships are out of this there's a
huge focus primarily on the story which
kind of sets the tone for the game which
is makes it like less lighthearted than
most fireman games are like you know
mission to mission there are
conversations you can have with people
during combat which to me personally
feel a little bit weird because there's
people trying to kill you and you're
just like joking with your friend about
some like old you know like thing you
guys have in common
everything is voiced to like a lot of it
most of it yeah I can't think of
anything that wasn't yeah so pretty much
and again you know the third-person
dungeon exploration stuff it's pretty
basic but it's not as unwieldy as it
might seem for a series that has never
really had that before yeah that's my
biggest question cuz I like I've seen
gameplay obviously like I read the
review I am not quite sure how that
exploration works this sounds like it's
a it's a positive thing for the game
like it provides variety but like
definitely are you doing so the three
things you can do during the game when
you're moving along the overworld map is
bump into an enemy and get in combat go
to a town and use almost like
point-and-click searching to like find
items and talk to people but then you
will come across dungeons as well and so
you sort of enter those from the map but
you go to it you click on it
uh and then it's just a third-person
thing and you're kind of exploring it's
not a huge space in the stuff that I've
seen so far you'll find items you'll
bump into enemies when you bump into an
enemy it breaks out into that typical
you know overhead 2d Fire Emblem battle
system it's it's not groundbreaking like
it certainly is an inventive like
compared to so many other games that are
dungeon-crawling rpgs but it does help
make this feel like a distinct fire
emblem for sure which I felt like fates
the biggest gimmick was the fact that
there are three versions of the game
yeah it was almost more of an annoyance
if anything yeah that's a big thing
where it's like cuz I know a lot of
people who skipped birth right because
they were Fire Emblem veterans then you
go like missed that piece of faith and
you go to conquest or revelation um
whereas it's nice to have something that
you know is standalone at least and
something that's more strategy focused
of course I'm bummed because I really
like the relationship stuff in recent
Fire Emblem games and in in any game um
so but I do appreciate having a it seems
like more focused especially because
it's focused on what two characters and
their respective armies yeah and frankly
it's you know it honors kind of fire
emblems roots as well so it's yeah it
might upset a few people who are more
used to the the you know today's fire
emblem stuff but I think for folks like
myself especially like I kind of enjoy
just a focus on the political conflict
and the military skirmishes and that
kind of thing XCOM 2 was one of my
favorite games last year and in terms of
the stripping the relationship things
from this I make the comparison just
because it's the turn-based kind of a
more strategic overhead kind of stuff do
you think I'll be interested in this be
coming from that background I think you
will I don't think like wow little I've
played of XCOM 2 I see there being very
more depth to the variables that you
have to manage in battle mm-hmm
this one is a little bit more
straightforward um I think you'll still
like it though I mean thematically it's
interesting early on like the game sort
of presents this intro story where it
shows these two characters as kids and
their friends and they're happy but when
you start the game the first thing
you see in the cutscene is one of them
stabbing the other one through the chest
and the other one missing on purpose
you're like Jesus like what the hell
happened so what kinda Gino and then go
back to the grid yeah yeah cuz you're
managing two armies throughout the game
right and one of them leads each of
those yeah we gave it a 9 out of 10 it's
up the reviews on game Spira now if you
want to go look at it you also wrote in
the notes
DLC model is dollar sign dollar sign
dollar sign insane dollar sign dollar
sign dollar sign that is the one cloud
hanging over this game it's a forty
dollar 3ds game the season pass for the
DLC which i think is like five packs
which probably includes a couple maps
and few items $45 damn more than the
game itself what's the game for word oh
I remember when you you were like yeah
cuz Peters is across from me so you
think we're like what the hell is really
sweet about it didn't you yeah of course
you did of course I did I love tweeting
and you don't tweet that much I was like
on my timeline last night I don't take
that much you don't really you were too
busy polishing your retro consoles don't
make me say it
yeah fireman uh is uh echoes I think
it's a really good game we have question
about it um let me pull my phone up
quick so I can go to Twitter in general
somewhat saying do you think it do you
think there is a fire emblem fatigue now
there are three games the three s that's
from Lloyd Christmas I'm feeling it a
little bit and yes that name is amazing
so you do think there's some fatigue
setting in I am feeling it a little bit
um but I think it's almost more in my
head than like a real thing is when I'm
actually playing the game I'm still
really engaged in it you know yeah like
uh even playing heroes on mobile yeah I
was like it just made me want to play
awakening like I didn't get tired of it
yeah yeah that's just I don't know I
can't be satisfied with fire but it's I
mean it's definitely interesting because
they're doing things differently than
the other games that we've seen that
does help mix up things so that the
fatigue isn't as bad as it might seem
what about the fire I mums on the switch
when Mata do we know anything about it
nope you know you know mama does
Tai was saying based on the information
that we have on fire mum switch should
we expect a return to forum with that or
will file
the current 3ds standards I guess I
don't I'm not privy to information hmm
they're mine those games aren't tied
down to the double screen like on 3ds
are they uh no it just sort of provides
you like a supplemental menu screen that
you can feel like stats for food yeah
yeah stuff like that yeah yeah cool
all right well like I said our view is
up on gamespot Heidi Kemp's right our
freelancer gave it a 9 out of 10 go read
that if you want more in-depth
information I'm going to be playing it
later today
Jake Decker is pretty pissed that I have
it because he likes fireman games a lot
about Friday right yes the 19th people
are talking about Fire Emblem warriors
which is different from the Fire Emblem
game on switch that we're talking about
yeah fireman warriors is the new so
right and then there's a different right
there's an intelligence since he's like
oh yeah Fire Emblem yeah yeah burn
button matching dynasty Warriors move so
kind of stuff right yeah
[Music]